okay let's go we need to talk about how to
describe vamanos let me know when Pat, we're good
rolling okay so hannah's talking i don't know what
to say are we rolling already yeah oh we jumped
in that corner oh yeah no i don't we don't you
you plan things out and put effort into your work
and you script it out and you don't know we just
go we don't even shower here as you can see not
even a 3-2-1 okay rolling nothing so we're going
we're going and we're done thank you so much for
being here all right my uber's here see ya that's
all we needed that 15 seconds for tick tock bye
um and we got it no i had such big plans about
impressing you today like i'm realizing that i
don't understand my generation what oh not yet
emily okay also you're here the first day that
emily is going to shoot me with a nerf gun if i
interrupt you no way yeah yeah oh can you shoot
me too look how many nerf darts i have it's a
it's a satchel she's got a set a bag i i'm gonna
shoot muzzles at your face i obviously have a tick
where i cannot not interrupt someone we're working
because you get excited i get excited i it's not
like it's okay it's okay because i get excited
i get excited just to hear you speak really yeah
you're such a legend okay anything that comes out
of your mouth i don't know what to expect that's
the take that's the take internet yeah there you
go just be excited okay because you're open arms i
love you that's so nice because i'm realizing i'm
uh intimidated by you no no no no okay
now i'm gonna interrupt you okay no
i'm intimidated by you this generation but i'm
also in awe of you you are just like a staple
for just women and comedy in general and you've
just paved the way to for so many people and so
many careers and i just look up to you oh and
my family they're all huge uh fans of you too
making me feel old this is her way of saying
like my grandmother loves you no and i've had
to sit through your shows and be like can we
watch pewdiepie please like no we're watching
our program whitney's on whitney is on
stop it stop it you're an actor no they
think it's a they think it's fran drescher's
new show they're like friends on and it's me
that is so no it's just that's that thank
you that's so nice but i realized like
you know i was like i want to like look good and
look cute and then i fully just look like vincent
gallo today you don't even know who that is i bet
hey uh i don't but i i'm telling you you look like
you know like every art teacher i had this whole
plan where i was gonna brush my hair i was gonna
put on like a top and here we go no this is uh you
don't you don't want to see my hair when it's not
done it is atrocious some is straight some is
curly at least you have consistency you've brushed
it i'm like i i had to get it done i can't do
it myself have you ever dyed bleach your hair
um i've bleached like the middle uh part
before it was atrocious it gets so dry
there's no way to not make it frizzy and i thought
i was having like a victorian like jane austen
moment with my victorian bun and i just look like
a like a dangerous person so i'm sorry you had
to meet me this way well now like that only took
you two seconds but now you look like a ballerina
but here's something in the future uh in la i
don't know how long you've been here but um if you
see a woman that looked like that don't hug her or
say hi go the other don't go into her house okay
i'm going to put it in my head i'm very protective
of you next time you see someone that looks like
this don't enter their home and let her close the
door behind you go the other way just be like no
way not to talk to strangers uh yeah so i realized
i was like nervous to meet you there's this weird
like i'm so in on you guys because i like cannot
wrap my head around how bad it would have been
if i had a camera in the internet when i was your
age oh so many people would be dead yeah i think
you know that's maybe yeah that's a good
a good point like but for me it's like
i can't imagine going on stage alone and
slanging jokes and making people laugh like that
i know are you so talented no that's so nice
but it's like it's just so interesting that
there's like a different my nightmare would
be sitting in front of like a computer and
like editing it and like not knowing i
guess i'm just gonna send this out and
i guess we'll just see yeah i know but i mean
the beauty comes in editing it's like with you
it's live and you can't rely on the
edit to take something out of it
nothing i'm saying when it's on nothing else oh
yeah this is live like i'm just authentic i'm me
i just want people to know the real me this is an
inside joke of our producers by the way you guys
because sometimes i will edit out like words i'll
be like i started on that line can you please take
it out oh yeah just hard cut i'm sounding if you
want to do an intervention you need to cut it i
sound unwell but you're just like i i love you
you come bearing gifts look at this i love buying
people presents it's kind of pathological
and inappropriate because we're not that
close you're like a stranger to me so the fact
that i bought you that six months was like weird
oh and when when we first met in real life i got
you a pray mantis [ __ ] yeah what is that are we
are we do we think we're not enough and we need to
give each other presents what is it i think every
time we see each other we can just take turns
giving each other now i feel pressure next time
i see him like [ __ ] no no next time it's my
turn but you know what's weird about me i don't
um i try not to do too many holiday gifts i like
to do gifts like when i want to give it's like i
want to give that now i don't want to save that
i'm going to break it by the time it's christmas
but i won't you won't get a christmas present
from me but you will get a random present like
in like february in college it's like oh it's you
know you're you're half birthday yeah i don't but
yeah i don't like that we can only give presents
on birthdays and uh the other one christmas i like
to do it just whenever but it's weird if i just
give it to you on a random i'm like i bought that
for you six months it was like weird why i i like
i like the the surprise element of it like you
never really know when it's coming it doesn't have
to be a holiday or a birthday i like the whitney
present giving way do your parents are just
nailed it or what why are you so well adjusted
what do you mean like i i thought the next
generation was like negative and like man like
you're such a like what kind like you're such a
bright light oh gosh um no i think uh yeah i think
it's i am oh golly jeepers oh gee willis like how
did you not how are you not a monster oh i would
be a monster you would oh my god like how like
what would you do okay i am uh i just turned 29.
so what okay and then what are you doing why
do you look like a piece of cake what's that
uh there's a caked up makeup
there you go i got my makeup done
i want to do this rapeseed oil though
we've talked about grape seed oil
yeah i think that's a secret no i do that and you
do that and we don't look the same so what else
because no no no i use that too and i don't look
like you so what's going on no but i want to do
with your face though is it a cake yeah with the
knife and that just slices it open i guess you had
to learn to do makeup really young because like
i would never you did you do your makeup no okay
yeah because that was made me upset yeah um yeah
no i think yeah when i when i do makeup it takes
you know 15 minutes it's just tinted moisturizer
a little bit of mascara it'll get on my eyelid but
i'll leave it there you know for a little
uniqueness um but yeah no regarding uh
you know my my upbringing yeah i think i owe it
a lot to my parents and especially therapy okay
therapy helps a lot did you go when you started
realizing you were famous were you just like i
should get into therapy see that's funny you say
that i still i mean i i think i'm known on the
internet i i wouldn't you know categorize
myself as being famous i i think that um
you know i just got no realization 20 million
followers like don't really know who you are
they just kind of followed you and like who
is this oh [ __ ] oh my god did you shoot it
let her finish okay let her finish about therapy
okay but i'm not here's the one thing i do
interrupt when i when someone that i have love for
i know it's inappropriate it's it's premature but
i feel like when you're like women's business you
just kind of bond prematurely if you say something
that i'm an international just don't um i like it
though because if you interrupt me i have severe
adhd so i immediately am on to the next topic
that's what this whole so i can't even remember
it was about therapy i forget my training yeah
yeah no we'll get we'll get you back don't worry
yeah yeah yeah yeah i have covered fog you have
adhd this pod has to be great this is like this
is just a peak listening experience how was your
your code it was it was i feel i'm so embarrassed
talking about it uh uh i have like shame about
it talking about it um because it was so bad
and i i got it so bad and i don't know people
talk about like did i get like a big viral load
or something which never say ride reload and
make eye contact with me jesus christ i was at
work yesterday and these people were like it was
the viral load i was like everyone stop saying
viral load jesus weirdly sexual because
you also don't know what you're saying
you don't know none of us know what that means
who made up that term i love it that people i've
never heard that before literally like actors like
so is the viral load you don't know what you're
asking and i don't know what i'm answering why
are we pretending we're doctors none of us know
[ __ ] anything you know what i mean so what's
your blood type i don't know and you don't care
but because you have a blood type a
you don't know if that's even true
yeah what is this performance and
then we're all just like performing
a covid conversation yeah and did you get the pcr
test yeah yeah but the pcr is related to the rapid
if you were to ask one more question the whole
house of cards would fall down yeah you know do
you know what a pcr test is and they're like oh no
i just have heard other people say that like we're
all just saying what we've heard other people say
in conversations no but i guess like nothing is
really set in stones everything is like
changing it's just such a new thing
no there's no point in like like i feel like
as soon as i learn something the next day it's
totally undone so i'm like i'm not gonna bother
learning anything until when the doctors tell
me what this [ __ ] thing is i'll learn it then
until then i'm just gonna assume it's gonna kill
everyone all the time but i was uh no i was and i
did uh uh i had it so bad but it was hard i got so
much neurological stuff and i feel we were talking
about it because i don't like scare anybody but
i don't think that's you can't you know what i
mean like because i got nothing respiratory was
all like neurological and i was like i didn't know
if it was from the antibiotics because i do very
poorly on antibiotics um like antiviral i don't
know i'm gonna say it i don't know okay i say that
i could have just bullshitted and be like yeah
no it was anti-virulent like what what does
that mean wait wait why did your generation
know about medicine we never knew anything
well i i also i have a pre-med degree though what
yeah i wait i knew you were like in biochemistry
um like six years ago yes but now it's
just like strictly videos and internet so i
i haven't been exercising that part no i disagree
because i look at your stuff and i'm like this
stuff is so like cerebral not that you're applying
like medical but it's like i don't think people
understand it requires so much discipline it
requires so much like dare i say like surgical
like watching your stuff a lot of people i don't
know how you have this it's a it truly is a gift
the understanding of and we talked about this all
the time emily like knowing when to cut the time
the comedic timing like when people say i
could never do stand-up the comedic timing like
it's not that's how i feel but you can't teach
anyone that you just have to do it it's trial
and error and there's no way to really tell
someone how it's and how to like make it your
own and differentiate yourself like you can't
like just copy somebody's style and like succeed
there goes our youtube career i was about to do a
big spelling bee video oh my god you saw that one
oh that's so funny are you having as much fun as
it looks like you're having i know i think that's
the beauty of of just starting out and then just
like seeing like what your creative freedom brings
you because there i mean there wasn't as many
eyes like that that was the most fun time for me
and you were incubated by fans not executives
yeah who were guessing what fans want yeah
you're like no i know my like you were focus
group workshopping with your fan base whereas
a lot of like writers people like i want to be a
writer and even actress i'm like go make videos
and do your thing because you're not going to be
able to get past all the gatekeepers and do what
you do exactly what i'm saying yeah because if
you had come to me ten years ago not me like i
would have thought it was awesome like but some
idiot had been like hey i want to do a video where
my eyes like go in circles and i because she has
done your research have you um i googled you this
morning did you feel it did you feel it i felt
i feel like you could feel my google yeah my eye
was going your eyes okay so what is it why do your
eyes do that um so your eyes go in circles i think
uh i think now is a great time to finally say
it and i've never said it like publicly but it's
the effects yeah the effect sorry i think that
would have been something i'm gay thanks thanks
for the hits thanks for the hits no please
no it's time to come out we need some youtube
subscribers yeah but you still can do some of it
you can do some of it you can do you can totally
that okay that's not [ __ ] vfx wait am i doing
it alone yes that is not very okay but i can't
you can grasp yeah you can definitely train
yourself you just threw a cover droplet at
me from doing that yeah gross from your eye just
shot out i don't think that's normal i don't is
it a muscle or is it a vein try it just cross your
eyes in the top you do it for me i think there's
something with your optic nerve kind of like being
undone that allows it to float but i don't think
anybody's really been able to control it like that
however i have heard from some fans being like
taking a picture of my specific eye video on
a powerpoint in their class and a professor is
actually teaching the class like oh yeah look
look at this girl she can actually move her eye
and dilate her pupils on command and like by the
way i love your impression of a teacher yo yo
where did you go to school that's cool
did you go to the dangerous mind school
it was a crazy like waldorf school um but let me
ask you something because it's like i do feel like
and then we're gonna watch this yolo video
i cannot wait um i do feel like there's
this like gen z what is it are you gen z i am a
millennial that's okay i think i'm kind of cool
yeah you're on the cusp about who gets
that i don't know yeah virgo rising got it
um are you virgo raising i'm virgo virgo
virgo double burger oh nice we get a lung
i'm an aquarius oh good no you just to get
along with virgo you just have to do exactly
what they say yeah and everything will be
fine and i'm a free bird so i'm like okay
as long as you do exactly what i say every
second perfect and we will beat you um
you keep entertaining me with your eyes we'll be
fine um no uh what was i saying what was i saying
i don't know do you remember it was important
you okay so why is this okay so i'm always
torn between this like you know because i think
it's just because it's like i came up in such
a specific time and then it like kind of got like
not easier in a way but it got um more accessible
things just got more accessible out of nowhere
um i think just like being able to start out make
something yes when i started you couldn't even
put yourself on tape for an audition you had to
find a friend who had a camera like that's like
what's so amazing about what you've been able to
do you've been able to navigate that extremely
hard space and become the legend that you are
and i think that like today it is hard to become
you know a weekly guest slot on our phone yeah i
would love that no but thank you so much but i
look at you and i do the opposite i go i would
have posted some i wouldn't have had any of
this because i would have posted something
[ __ ] if half the [ __ ] i said in comedy
clubs when i was just making mistakes and
learning i had put on camera and put out right
oh i would be living in a bunker with matt lauer
in the hamptons like in a whole somewhere
yeah like the fact that you you have to be
here's the thing that i love about you guys you
have to be a good person because i don't think you
can get away with it as long as we could like like
old hollywood whatever these they could get away
with being [ __ ] for so long because number one
you don't really see their personality you guys
can't hide that as much as you yeah you know their
team kind of covers for them yeah and then there's
everything's being you know and now and in this
space too sorry oh my god i i deserve it i'm sorry
um no but but i'm just saying there's
something so amazing by going like
i know all of you guys are good people mm-hmm and
there's something just like kind of heartening
about that yeah because i know you can't hide
anything yeah we can't and then also like i
would say in my space collabing is such uh do you
know my spaces oh yeah were you on it i was yeah i
had uh top eight and everything but i think i was
like on the i had it for like the last like three
months dude i saw tom from my space on mariah no
i'm sorry wait i think i just peeked this down
and he and he uses his photo from
myspace which i just was like oh it's
so good he was my like right like almost
everybody still my friends my best friends
did you match with him no i don't know what i
did i can't remember i think i took a nyquil i
don't remember but i also i'm dating someone what
am i saying um uh but uh but no there's this but
you like i remember watching you and going like
you i was watching some interviews last night on
it wasn't like podcasts or something um and it
was very awkward because i think what happens
with uh is people just expect you to start
going into us doing a sketch and you're like
oh yeah i know interviews are awkward right
interviews yeah extreme is this one awkward
i'm not i mean i think the idea of a podcast
is very awkward with all these cameras around
and people watching and having a conversation
first date yes but with you you make it so fun
and easy thank you yeah i'm i'm amazing i'm just
trying out for my weekly guest spot right now um
but uh no but what why do you have to be off set
like i was watching you religiously i try to be
authentic and i remember being like why why i
think it's just like why can't you [ __ ] do
cgi and do like what is the hold on just help me
understand this so people you want to see superman
and michael bay movies and cgi and then
but they have that you know i think it's
like the relatability aspect of you know young
girls say they wake up in the morning and they
don't look perfect like every other actress
does in a movie you know and they want to see
you know some people do sorry sorry what i'm
getting in trouble oh you want to shoot me do it
oh my god oh my god holy [ __ ] i'm so sorry that
could have taken your eye out oh my god oh my god
the the ephemeral joy in your eyes right before
it almost killed me and she whipped it out like
by the way that is that is a woman in her
late 30s in a nutshell i'm doing my job sorry
let's uh not say late thirties okay friday okay
okay that's embarrassing in front of me we're
the same age just so now every time i heard your
feelings i hurt my own just now just know we're in
this we're in this together i'm not just hurting
you i'm also cutting okay that hurt me more i
think than it hurt you actually okay the problem
with this is that it's interrupting so much that i
now we can't even go back to where we're just
talking yes we can but we don't have to be a super
on like okay like like there's two things i have
in my head that i want to make sure we don't we
go back to it could be like a brain gym exercise
like any time we interrupt each other just boom
and then we could see if we still remember
what we were doing when liza koshy was here
i wasn't even on camera like we went back through
the footage and there was like nothing intelligent
it was just like like we didn't we're just talking
at like 300 miles an hour like no there was no
you i feel like hold on let's eliza koshy it's
just like um guttural noises the podcast it's
just us being like crazy um but you guys have
such infectious like positive energy but why do
you so do you i'm that yes i'm known for my uh uh
positive essence uh but why why do you have to be
when you're making a video you're like
i have to be relatable i have to be this
but why can't you be aspirational or why can't
anyone can photoshop their eyes now with a thing
that is inspiring to me to go
yeah i want to be as good as her
yeah i think um which is it do you want to be
perfect or do you want to be relatable which is it
because you want both because when i'm relatable
and don't wear makeup you say that i'm busted
and when i do my makeup you say you're creating
a false a bad standard what is it so you just
do that she interrupted me get her that back she
interrupted my ramble that's the that's the battle
that i'm i'm always facing because if i am trying
to be relatable i am getting negative comments
about my body image or how my face looks or
something like that but you kind of just have to
bite that bullet and just try to be inspirational
to the young women out there and hope you can
be that role model and then if you are being
perfect then people are like is that photoshop
but yeah you just kind of have to like take again
but here's the thing here's the other thing about
that cause i was talking to someone yesterday who
was like talking about comments people are allowed
to be insecure and have a shitty day and
anesthetize by judging someone else or saying we
just used to do it not in the comments section so
for people like people so negative on the internet
people just negative period they've always done
this there was just never any proof yeah there
was never any way for us to access it so i have
news for you 15 years ago people were like i don't
[ __ ] like her she's not funny but we just didn't
know about it people like the [ __ ] internet
assistant oh and now you know about it just so you
know the truth is out this was always happening
people were always judging you and saying [ __ ]
that may or may not be true it may not be unfair
is cruel and mean but like what is nice about it
is if i put out a video and it's just all like
negative comments i know it's not going to be a
good video and i just take it down immediately so
thank you haters now by the way you're just
making me better at my job that's i look at
haters yeah as like um well because this is when
tim dillon was on and he was attacking hollywood
and he was a good [ __ ] hollywood stupid you have
to get notes from stupid executives know nothing
about comedy on the internet i have to get notes
from people that know nothing about comedy who are
so much meaner that don't have an hr department
absolutely yeah i kind of miss these old like
like like creepy guys like getting free
constructive criticism right there half
full yeah i mean that's what i love about your
mindset you're very glass-half-full interesting
i mean we're literal strangers so it's like it's
just you're gonna meet me at some point and be
like oh and that's why i try to get the podcast
before the person gets to know me jen i'm saying
why like why did you go into therapy was it like
i just want to get ahead of it or is it like a
specific thing i think it was it was a built up
thing that i just kind of thought like things
are just superstitious so i'm just ripping on
my hair for no reason and then i just thought
you know i should go to therapy my mom suggested
it and i went in and you know it was i've never
really like been that person to really when
was this i i started like were you famous
yeah i started therapy like three years ago
okay so you had already had a lot of stuff
yeah had stuff coming at you i bet yeah
totally and then i've always like been
very just like i'm detached i don't really
express my feelings so i would say like just
people listening if you're listening to this and
you're not really good at expressing your feelings
to certain people like therapy is actually like
the best thing because you pay them not to say
anything and you can trust them and it's at the
end of the day it's like a massage for your brain
it really is like that's such a
great way to put it like it's like
i don't have to like rush through that like it's
like there i mean you do you have 45 minutes and
there's a clock right there it's [ __ ] 30 a
minute but i mean i do feel like i'm really
curious and how you know that you're emotionally
what did you just say that you're reserved or
you're yeah i mean i've always been that way i've
always yeah it's not that you're not having the
feelings that you're just like don't want to be
private about it yeah interesting like i just
deal with it alone but if you're like i've never
felt a feeling i've hear about them and i'm like
i think about that no i i mean when i was
feeling those feelings alone i wish i was
that yeah i was like how do i just you felt them
but you feel them and you're just like because i'm
so curious like i'm really good at suppressing
the emotion until and then i give myself like
okay at eight i'm off and then i can cry yay and
then i give my my schedule yeah yeah i schedule
nervous breakdowns too is that what you're
trying to say yes she's like no oh i love
that we can relate on that i just snotted
on myself um so okay so that's so but this
is part of the reason you're successful too
because this is something that um i was uh uh
with david de agus the other day a doctor
that comes on the podcast sometimes and i
a big problem with uh me having coveted when i
had it for anyone um i wasn't taking my regular uh
antidepressants because i was like i just couldn't
keep food down and i was like sick and i was like
you know um trying to take painkillers and like i
was ordering like weed tinctures like just because
painkillers like is that hey we're so sweet um
painkillers don't uh uh didn't work on it for
me on it at all because i had so much like deep
muscle pain and bone pain you know i had that too
i couldn't walk i was trying to work out and i was
like working out but i just i couldn't i couldn't
i wouldn't go away took a nightmare yeah um
and it would wake me up out of my sleep yeah
nightmare yeah and so i didn't take my prozac and
i wasn't um in the prozac i basically take four uh
recurring thoughts that are kind of
self-flagellating and then go on a loop so
i like done work in 12-step programs in therapy
but like i talked to psychiatrists where i was
like i don't think i'm depressed like i don't wake
up sad i want to get out of bed i'm if anything
it's the opposite i'm too motivated i'm too big
of a workaholic like i should slow down more
like whatever i'm addicted to adrenaline and um
and i was like the only problem is i will leave
a conversation with someone and just feel like you
should have said that that was stupid oh i'm like
that too 40 minutes it's like 40 minutes i will
say like i could be like that for the whole rest
of the day and then it will keep me up all night
yeah no i wonder i i hope i didn't hurt anybody's
feelings i hope that that was weird yeah meanwhile
they're like i just had a great time with hannah
or they're not thinking about you at all yeah
they knew or they're thinking the same thing
they're going to say hannah i should have and then
like the beating myself up thing and it's like
i don't know how to stop it at the end of the
day they're just like oh i wonder what i should
eat for lunch yeah no like yeah it's not even
that serious you're just like it's like this
it's like the new um uh like it used to be like
like i finally got used to getting recognized in
public and then i and as soon as i got used to it
um people would have their phones out you know and
like people are taking pictures and they're like
taking pictures of them selfies like i was in um
or they're on facetime yeah the phone's up and
then you're like oh god just ask for a picture
and they're like who are you ma'am are you
the lady from the progressive commercial um
that's funny i get kimmy gibler all the time
whoa you guys see that i don't see no i don't no
not like i think without without
the glam if i were to like do that
just go cross-eyes yeah if i would i could see
it if my eyes were going in circle uh yeah no
i see i get it i get it i mean but people don't
realize how hurtful they can be when they do that
like just before you compare someone to
someone else not that she's not stunning now
you know what i'm saying it's just making me think
gibbler is a gay a baby last time last night was
the first uh uh i guess it was first time i've
been around people and everyone's like bored and
awkward and on a set and it's so clear people
haven't been socializing like everyone's like
like the small talk is really awkward and far away
and it's like what like no one can people are just
sweating for no reason we can hear each other
through the mask we're going to shake it don't
do it let's not talk let's just not talk
it's not it's like not even worth it
it's like so awkward but there's always everyone's
going you know who you look like and you're like
you want to take a walk and think about
this because this might [ __ ] up my whole
day i get kevin costner i've had
three people tell me i don't know
like kevin costner and then i did that face
app of like well now you have to take the math
okay put it back you don't you don't no you
don't you took a second yeah no no i took
a second trying to think of who kevin did that
face up where you take it and it'll tell you what
percentage and i got michael costner kevin i got
kevin oh my god i got kevin i can't see it i got
that's kevin costner fog that's
rage that's that's deep anger
and and female rage uh that's deep shame that was
not that was that's my thing about the copenhagen
i want to go like kobe fox and it's like no
i think you're just being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i like like my dude my dude my lover any
time he's mad at me i'm like i think he's
covered [ __ ] he's like no you you texting
your ex at midnight it's not covet fog right
how much longer can i ride out this excuse me
i need to be on the bottom covered fog i just
can't be able to i don't know how much longer
i can use that excuse me we now take a break in
our hannah stocking joy extravaganza to talk
about how emily needs stitch fix i do i hate
all my clothes i don't like to dress myself if
someone could dress me i want to be a baby here's
here's here's because this is a basically a
personal stylist that you take a bunch of quizzes
and they just send you clothes that are cool
and fashionable and you don't have to make any
decisions and you don't need a subscription see
that's why emily's here she focuses on the details
the nitty-gritty that i would never have read
in this ad that's an important thing so you're
not obligated yeah you can try it once or you can
sign up for automatic delivery see that as someone
with commitment issues i really appreciate that i
don't want to be everything for me has to be month
to month subscriptions relationships police leases
employees antidepressants this is like every month
i need to revisit so one thing you shouldn't
do month to month every month i'm like i don't
let's try a new one let's and that could be why
why we're here that's why we're here isn't it
god damn it get started today at stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix that's stitchfix.comwhitney
for 25 off when you keep everything no offense
but if you're listening you need this
stitchfix.com whitney come be a baby with me
babies don't i guess they do have wardrobes
yeah they get dressed someone picks their
clothes and gets them dressed so it's true
stitchmate you want to wear onesies all day
hey emily yes whitney is there something
interfering with your happiness or is preventing
you from achieving your goals now don't say me
how long do please donate we're trying to keep
these less than a minute right yes i have a list
of grievances i have a litany of problems that
could probably be solved by just quitting this
show one of my biggest problems is that therapy's
too expensive it's not only too expensive always
just too far it's time expensive it's emotionally
expensive 45 minutes i expressed to my therapist
anxiety about having to spend 240 an hour for 40
minutes people are like what's bothering you the
price of this and you know what's the distance of
this from my home and she didn't have any helpful
feedback on that because just like smile and nod
can we just really quick talk about the fact
that emily went to a therapist once on halloween
this is my favorite this we shouldn't bury
this in an ad i hope you this will teach
you guys to not skip ads because our ads
are better than the podcast at this point
um emily went to a therapist on halloween and he
showed up in a fox costume and didn't dress up
he was a cat oh she was a cat with a black nose
whiskers ears and a tail and a tail a bushy tail
and first session first session and he was
a psychiatrist this was a medicine doctor
and it was a random wednesday it was like
a rant it wasn't you know what i mean like
and it was at a doctor's office like
i he walked in and i almost fell over
right dude and the fact that you sneaked oh and
then i sneaked two pictures oh we'll put them up
i sneaked two pictures and he sat down and looked
at me seriously and tried to talk to me about like
my mental health as a cat as a cat meow i was like
what so i left with a prescription i didn't need
for my cat allergies for my allergies yeah i
don't even remember his name but i was just like
it was comical by the way if you knew his name
don't say it no the pokemon yeah if you remember
it please don't say it i don't trust any adult
that comes to any psychiatrist on my bad side
but i don't need any adult i'm sorry if you do
this like adults that come to work dressed for
halloween i already have a problem with you're
gonna try to help me so emily maybe we could work
on your anger issues with betterhelp.com you need
betterhelp.com i definitely do better emily needs
betterhelp.com online therapy to complain about
her in-person therapists yes 100. 100 um so as you
look doing therapy in person i just feel
like that was ridiculous we had a good run
so 2019. not necessary anymore betterhelp.com is
solving this problem that better help is like when
restaurants learned about like fast food model
and you're like oh this is so much faster yeah
betterhelp.com is more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is available
this podcast is sponsored by better help and good
for you listeners get ten percent off their first
month at betterhelp.com slash whitney if you're so
if your idea terrorizes you while you're working
you can sue her and then go to battlesome.com
but then go to betterhelp.com thank you
betterhelp.com for better help are you going
to do live shows when we're back like comments
you've done some yeah i will appreciate that as
a fan i think that's just like such a muscle and
such an amazing thing you have to do more you have
to tour something yeah i don't know i i do that
i don't know yet you can use why not i'll have
you put like a stage show together no yeah
i'll take 90 percent of the profits uh but i'll
help you and i'll help you just friend a friend
i'll tell you where we just want to support other
women if me you and tim dillon just went on like
your demo and his demo in the
same building no thank you
kids and then dylan that would be that would
be fun literally like yeah no i don't yeah
like i don't his fan base would have to
uh ask for a respite from prison i think
you have to like to get out to come and go back
there's no way but yeah you have to tour no way
gosh but you can do you can do an interactive
thing like i think people think tori and the way
touring's going to come back doesn't look
very different than the way it was before
so doing stuff on a screen and playing videos
and doing you know oh yeah absolutely yeah i just
have my own little twist on it and i do have an
excessive amount of energy i still consider this
the morning just because i woke up so early so
i'm not peak energy so what i do need to release
is this just joy what is it is this just a good
childhood i don't know what is it oh my my energy
oh the therapist i don't know you're just having
like so i think i used to be like this actually
no no i think i used to have energy i look at
her by the way you're looking at yourself in 10
years so just just but you you have the energy
though not really you're lifting me up a little
bit what i realize is like this i normally
am like kind of almost bordering on manic but
i am it's terrific it's true like i have kind of
a manic energy and i think that a year into the
pandemic i realized i started to get depressed
i just started to get like okay this is getting
i i think i channel yeah i channel that into
just i know that there's just so much energy
and it needs to be released i need to scream once
you gotta let it out where do you what do you do
something i mean anywhere let me ask you with your
the people that you have on like i'll see someone
go like viral on whatever what does that even
mean how many is there a definition for that um
i think viral is like what does that mean
i think if like if other meme pages pick
up on it and start reposting it and yeah it's
like it spreads everywhere like a viral load
of viral i was always curious because people
will say they'll be like that video went viral
i'm just like so curious is there a number that
or is it subjective i think i think the number is
subjective but i also think that it's it's how
much it spreads i think we should pick a rule
also i think it is subjective because i think
if a video does over 40 million that's viral
oh jesus christ so how do you
do you know that that is like
40 million views i mean that's three friendses in
terms of numbers yeah like i don't think you guys
understand how much more successful you are than
you're the people you look up to i'm just i'm just
telling you from a number no it's like i'm just
telling you i i'm worried about you like i don't
like you guys are famous in a way that's like so
wild and yeah yeah do you know what i'm saying
it's wild in this sense like i i feel like with
you it's it's you see your fans you interact with
your fans for me it's all behind a screen yeah
so i don't actually see and interact with them as
much unless i leave my house and then i'm like oh
yeah sometimes there are times where i'm looking
around like who are they what are they running
towards or something because i forget i'm just
i don't see it first yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so
interesting but you guys i mean it's like there's
a you know the biggest tv show like say comedy
is probably like six million probably what do
you mean uh viewers yeah oh yeah yeah i mean it's
like these it's just like it's a different kind of
fame that there's no blueprint for and just this
is not gonna end well for you i'm just saying
there's no bloopers yeah you can definitely yeah
it's different than it's not like disney channel
it's not like being a child star it's not like
being famous yet it's a different kind of fame
that no it is a gamble it's like some days
you crush and you just produce heaters or
you produce deleters okay you just gotta delete
them yeah because it just doesn't perform well
but are there ever times where you're just
what's wrong with that what do you mean
like it doesn't perform yeah what's wrong with
just being like man that one's for me i think uh
are you like your business so you have to go like
this has to hit and also with what i do it's just
immediate instant gratification uh because you
just see all the numbers flood in and then when
you post something that doesn't get the right
numbers it's like gosh it's like i almost fallen
a lot of people do i've talked to other internet
people and they also fall into the little ethers
almost and they're just like hey gosh you know
like i'm not getting the rush of serotonin or
anything or dopamine what's what's going on yeah
and so it's just like it's addictive so rat race
yeah so for you it's like it's it's interesting
so is it yeah as content creators you guys it's a
little more like the gauge is is is your instinct
where it's like in tv and movies you don't get to
pick if something comes out or doesn't or where
it comes out right and if you pull it down like
you don't get to say like i didn't like that let's
can we pull it down you're like right like i'm in
that embarrassing movie you know yeah so it's like
it's a lot of like your judgment oh yeah pretty
much and then managers and i'm yeah that same
rush feeling i feel like it probably correlates
for you if you get like a big explosive laugh huh
um yeah i've gone a little numb what happens is is
it it's the the the what is it the thing what's
it the goal post move is that the expression
i keep saying the covet fog is also making me
say like dumb [ __ ] like yesterday i was like
you can lead a horse of water but you can't teach
it to fish like what i don't think something my
grandpa would say i'm like mixing up platitudes
like i don't know what that like i'm just like
it's just making me dumber it just makes me dumber
yeah and you know how it annoys me because it's
ah it's this is the [ __ ] this virus is so [ __ ]
it's the perfect uh covet fog perfectly feels like
someone's drunk like kind of you know like
i'll just i'll just be like anyway still um
what yeah what were you talking about i know it
seems like i'm alex lerner because uh the these
he said these muscles kind of stopped working
up here oh no way yeah yeah not botox i just
had like a little like neurological stuff in my
head oh just you specifically specifically yeah
a lot there's some other people that had like
bells paws but that could have been from stress
or something else because i was like yeah i
had a lot of crazy [ __ ] i that reminds me
and i do i want to circle back and hear about
your hallucination where you broke your nose
it's how you just breathe into it it's
just so embarrassing because i know that
everyone's building a case that i like need an
intervention there's something very wrong with me
unless yeah if you don't want to talk about it
we don't yeah it's literally i mean emily can
tell emily knows more about me than anyone it's
truly just i'm this nuts i'm ju i like i know
i wish i could say like you guys i had a bad run
with whiskey and that's over and i'm back on the
wagon my thing is like i don't know what i wish
i could say like well that addiction's over i'm
like nope that's still just my personality oh god
uh but uh wait so you weren't like i don't want
anything i was so paranoid i got really paranoid
because it was a kind of pain where you go
like i felt like i was like fighting for my life
it wasn't like i'm just gonna i'm definitely gonna
survive this and i'm just gonna like watch your
shit's creek and like get in bed and like have
a couple sick days this was during covet right
when you had covered this is when i covered yeah
but normally it's just like i have the flu i'm
being sick or i can work through it or whatever
this was a type of sick where i was like i was
like making plans i was like calling i was like
like i need to put a will together
i was like making plans for
who was gonna inherit my house like that's
how like fight or flight it got for me no way
because it was a type of like pain that was like
it was like um uh a ghost was like beating me up
no way i mean like i was just like oh like
it was like did you see the invisible man
i did i did yeah you're just like you're
just getting like knocked across the room
that was yes it was like it was like that because
just there you i i don't know how you but i it
wasn't like okay my stomach hurts and it's gonna
it was like this rib hurts and then it was like
this knee like i it felt like you're just getting
shot no way is that where you had emily i had like
i said this like uh i felt like you know how you
clip in and out of a bike or like as someone puts
a cigarette out you like twist your foot i
feel like someone was doing that all over
my body putting cigarettes out on like not the
burning but just the physical you didn't like that
that's not a thing a little nice little way
like that sounds amazing but just like they were
twinges they were like sporadic twinges okay so
i want to talk about this because you wait first
sorry to cut you off how did she get shot because
you don't do it to guess how how did you hit your
nose oh [ __ ] sorry okay because yes this is
okay so and here's what i'll say i just want
everyone to know i do not lie if i lie it's an
accident okay i just forgot and just got confused
but so i it's gonna sound like a lot of the
things that happen to me sound like lies
because but why wouldn't this is just your life
the problem is so fascinating it's like the thing
when people like always thought i lied about my
age my thing was like i didn't the reason the
only way i can get you to believe me is to just
know that why would i make up that age i would
never get away with it so know if i was gonna
lie i'd give myself a little wiggle room like
um so i am in bed like in pain what time is
it pain yeah pain four in the morning okay
i love that in the morning and i couldn't
sleep i was i'm gonna i snorted a lunesta
told me to do this it's a sleeping
pill you don't have trouble sleeping
so you crush it yourself no i crushed it finally
the doctor was like because i couldn't keep
it down i couldn't keep a painkiller down
there's like a hundred dollar bill i can't
do you think i would know how to get cash
myself wait so so you crush it up yourself
and just i know so i crushed it up with
a spoon and it was like snorting lunesta
i snorted a percocet i was is this crazy
we are not we are i'm so glad we started
in this business we are not endorsing
this behavior look this is this is crazy
i am a self-help authority i'm an authority
on all things health me and joe rogan are real
doctors listen to us yes so i swear and i so
it was like i snorted a little percocet i also
ordered this weed i was in so much
pain all that's right i'm surprised
more people aren't dying from overdosing on
on drugs trying to stop the pain jesus yeah
i was i was taking like four advils a day
too but not nothing compared to what you did
so you like candy okay great like what like
ad what's an anvil i take four advil every
morning when i'm feeling you're talking about
she's like every morning just to get out of bed
i take four hours a day just for this i
take it because i'm 30 years you're like i
drink like i drink the liquid gels to hydrate
myself um and so okay so i'm staying at a
different house because my house is being
renovated and i i do not understand the
the way people design their homes every home i go
into i'm like this house makes absolutely no sense
yeah i feel that way too anything made sense
which is obviously my fault everyone's got their
own thing i'm sure people come to my house and
like this literally there's by the bed there's
the coffee table by the master is about the size
of this table right it's like it's like a coffee
table yeah that's crazy side side tables are side
they're supposed to be small with a little drawer
put your little dining room table yeah put
your whatever your suicide note in there
your lube whatever you keep in the side
of your thing whatever polar opposites
of what you just said to the lube i don't know
tissues and whatever you keep by there you know
your your alex baldwin autobiography whatever
you have by your bed without whatever you want
the normal stuff that everybody has by their back
right um and so uh uh i was so cold i don't know
when you had cover you just i was freezing yeah i
was too terrible chills yeah the chills like i was
just like so cold and i woke up and i was like
so cold i started getting angry too like like i
had severe frustration too until i started crying
i was like what are my body aches gonna go away
and i just started shooting tears
out of my eyes it was just so sad
you're like an actual meme just yeah yeah
yeah but that's what it is those cartoons
yeah but it it's a thing where it's like because
there's no if someone's irritating if someone just
said you're gonna be sick for ten days it's gonna
suck and i'm like great and everyone was having
the same thing because then you get this like well
she only had for two days am i making this up am i
being historic is this like i started it became
like being in a haunted house with my own mind
like it got into like maybe i'm not this sick
maybe i'm making up maybe i am being dramatic
i don't know because then it's like you think it's
your fault if it's worse yeah because what did you
do to make it worse on what's your blood type
oh it's okay is that even set in stone is that
an actual thing yeah yeah like i failed somehow
because my cove is really bad and it's just like
it's just like embarrassing and people feel too
sorry for you so you don't even want to tell them
and then also when you tell someone you had it
they don't they it doesn't make them feel better
yeah it's like about being writing is even a real
thing yeah because but they're like i got you know
everyone's like you got the antibiotics and then
when you have them no one's like through anybody
someone's like oh you had covenant i know it
doesn't help it really doesn't say i had coveted
i'm safe does not make people feel more safe
absolutely not so how did you hit the wall oh god
um so oh my god she's like had it with me no i'm
just so curious this story keeps getting like
crazier and crazier it's amazing the people want
to know i should not have a podcast i cannot keep
stam on top for more than five minutes like why
am i doing this i'm so bad at this job it's wild
oh this is why you have a podcast that's amazing
that's right you just like go on conversations yes
um and so uh but i know what it's like to be
on a podcast and the host being like go back
to the thing i want to enjoy this too like i
want to hear the end of the story do i get to
have any say in how this goes um okay so
middle of the night i got a space heater
a [ __ ] amazon i was so cold the night before
to put the space heater in uh uh uh it was like
under the table and it wasn't i kept turning it on
it wasn't plugged in and i was like oh and i bent
over to plug it in the only reason we know this is
because there's blood on the table we found that
later i thought i walked into a beam and so uh we
found it later i slam my nose trying to i slammed
it was literally just like i just was like it's
what must have happened because there's just like
a blood on the you know thing and uh uh i went
back to bed that's how [ __ ] high i was and then
uh my lover said at six in the morning i crawled
into his room like so dramatic like crawling oh
yeah because i i felt dried blood on my face
because i always put oil on my face like the
first time when i wake up is grape seed oil
on my face and i was like i felt crustiness
and this is how sick i am at first i was like
why is my skin so dry and then i looked in the
mirror and was like oh thank god it's just oh my
gosh you're like well at least i'm moisturizing
oh my god it's just dried blood okay oh god i was
worried that i was dehydrated every second i saw
a christmas food start to form my gosh so what
made you think that you ran into a bean because
in this house there's a beam you're tall which
i have questions about how tall how young were
you when you got this tall oh i was pretty young
it's a it's a kind of trauma yeah it yeah and then
i i was very skinny i think i was five ten pounds
really traumatic oh wow 90 pounds in middle school
in like seventh grade wow yeah is that why
you like like to work out and get so strong
um i think uh i think that's i mean i've always
grown up very athletic i have always had this
kind of energy that i need release so i've always
been in sports and um like i think you should be
the wonder woman oh my god don't you think sweet
of you but i was also i also played volleyball
in college too so oh so that's what that is i do
now work out once a month not a lot uh what what
yeah yeah yeah do you bank it and then post it in
your store okay maybe that's yeah yeah okay maybe
that's recycled recycle the content i think that's
what i think is important now like i will when
people say like this is an unrealistic expectation
of my life too yeah well like do you know what
i'm saying like this isn't like this is what bums
it's like are we supposed to be balancing out the
unrealistic with the realistic this is what i'm
about time how are people able to wake up so early
i'm presenting the best version of this oh
the version i want you i'm curating a version
yeah that isn't embarrassing like why is that why
aren't people like you need to embarrass yourself
on children media and you need to reveal all
your secrets and you need to tell everyone
you're molested and post photos of you that make
up like no i signed up for a business where you go
you they make you look the best you've ever looked
that's what people see and then people don't see
the other stuff exactly exactly i mean it's hard
it's hard waking up in the morning working out
having sweat in your hair you have to
shower you have to wait for your hair to dry
and then put on hair and makeup and try to
figure out this this mess yeah but it's like
yeah it's like i don't know it's just like
it's just creating an unrealistic standard
well like if i didn't look like this you
wouldn't follow me so what would i do
you like them you like me doing the makeup so what
is it what is it i know yikes yeah what do you
want you have to balance so much pressure i feel
like you do you feel pressure to be a role model
um yeah i do um i think you i definitely want
you to know to do everything like there's so
many platforms there's so many videos there's so
much more i could be doing at all times i'm sure
maybe you feel that way too but i think it's
just you know the business that we're in
so you do have this because it does like i
think that like i realized that um i almost
preferred the [ __ ] up dysfunctional system of
uh hollywood television because at least like
you couldn't work unless you were at work right
whereas now i can't imagine like like being 29
and being able to like make something at any point
and upload it because as for me as like in my like
workaholism and my like desire to overcome and
make it like the only thing that stopped me from
like having a full like heart attack or a major
health crisis or like just not taking care of
myself like destroying myself and probably like
an adderall addiction in my 20s was me going like
well i have to go to bed now because i can't shoot
anything because i don't right the camera people
are at a building tomorrow that i have to go to
exactly you have to wait until they're there it's
it's all consistency and motivation that's that's
what it comes down to so what do you do did you
just teach yourself to edit uh yeah yeah i'm i'm
self-taught 100 uh because i went to school for
for pre-med and then i kind of just fell into it
what kind of bed did you think you wanted to do
um i i was gonna go into surgery i wanted to
be a surgeon that's what editing is pretty much
i know yeah you're right you're honest freaking
smart thank you no but it is it is dissecting
rearranging editing used to i don't know what
kind of surgery you're doing you don't move
things from the front where you're going to
pee at plastic surgeons just like this here
yeah see what this intestine looks like this looks
better than that the game of opera aesthetically
i like this better oh i know you like your
lungs there but it does look so much better
just like hear me out shoot me out so emily have
you um seen any balls recently you know what i
have not seen balls since i got broken up with um
i'm really looking forward to the next now you're
just bragging i've seen a lot of balls since she
went through your breakup i told you that that
crazy man in my apartment tried to see me with the
crossbow came out butt naked that's the first pair
of balls i saw tried to shoot you with a crosstalk
me and four police officers in a in an elevator so
the takeaway from this story is if that man had
just used manscape on his balls you would have
been you would not have had a problem with this
behavior right it would have been a more pleasant
first ball sighting post my relationship
it would have been a more pleasant attack
on me more aesthetically you guys are going to
attack women in a hallway with a sword what was it
a a crossbow you gotta shave your balls first
or i also think you're crazy do you know what
i'm saying you gotta use the ball wipes these
are deodorizing ball wipes that you know what
i did not put i'm gonna use on my armpits right
now and we'll see how they how it goes oh great
they're deodorizing moisturizing and anti-chafing
for on the go ball camera oh how does it feel
it's pretty soft here's what i'm
saying normally when you use a man's
products they're not good right they're like
they're rough they're they're coarse no one put
any thought into it but manscape they're making
like quality products for men they realize men
there's been a reckoning and women no longer want
rug burn on our chins we have to go to work now
so you have to pull your balls
together emily you're smelling that
this is just my armpits though it's the
bigger problem but it smells like a boyfriend
so uh wait were we doing the betterhelp.com
ad no this is for mansion okay got it okay
so yes go please yeah they have tons of amazing
men hygiene products on their website everything
from disposable mats for your pubes to deodorant
i'm sorry am i getting in trouble for saying
this is not just for guys this thing the look
at this it's a what do you call this it's a
like a portable get top kit it's a tiny stuff
you need for your nails in one place which i
first had a problem with because i've seen enough
men cut their nails on a plane while we're flying
no fly list don't please don't do that um but
this is yeah men having portable nail clippers
this is gonna win win for everyone backfiring
uh on a plane but what yeah just because guys
think they should just right right right right
cut their toenails like right near sinks right
the guy i'm dating put his foot up on i was like
can you do that in a sink like just or a toilet
i walk in his foots up on the kitchen sink i'm
like dude not that i ever go near that sink
but i'm sure that's gross for someone that will
100 crop reviver is spray on toner for your balls
yes please toner is great these and balls all
look like they're 100 years old for some reason
they need this they age they look like like dried
apricots elephant ears not anymore cleanser hair
and body wash yes please so 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code whitney
that's 20 off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code whitney thanks manscape for making
our winter wieners look so good honestly i'll
apply it if you guys will start using it i will
put it on your to them now that's how we
need to start selling this i'll set up a
different email for that i will is if you
i'll apply it if you use it how about that
uh and then i'm gonna need a new job so okay um
bandscaped thank you i am truly obsessed with the
um lollipop drinks okay when you guys look at our
podcast table and see the 900 just cans of trash
but it just looks like a yard sale in here
it's because i got obsessed with olipop it is a
supports digi it's a so it's like a healthy
soda the only thing i've ever wanted in life
a soda that doesn't make you feel like [
__ ] and make you feel bad about yourself
it's an alternative to soda it tastes like a coke
or whatever or like they've got all these like
vintage flavors where's the strawberry did
i drink it there's a cream strawberry flavor
that i i think i drank it already um but it's
got only three grams of sugar non-gmo vegan
paleo keto friendly less than eight grams net
carbs per can now what what wowza like wowza
like you i mean i know you like to like get
into your shame spirals with your regular sodas
that have proven to give people numerous uh health
problems so which one do you want to try do you
want to try the vintage clothing i want to try
vintage i'm going to have emily try one i'm very
excited the ginger lemon this is the sparkling
tonic that is sometimes i'll put a little
little drank in here do i mean all right emily's
trying her first olive pop it's a hundred percent
money back guarantee for orders place that's good
that's good right hold on i'm going to try that
i have the root beer one it tastes like i'm at
the soda shop it does it tastes like you're down
at the getting a phosphate i love it yeah the
alternative but i'm saying like i feel like as
an adult i can't just be pounding soda anymore
yeah i used to drink so much soda but this is i
still drew but this would be a much better option
i mean look how much look at this oh it's so much
less calorie by the way but the root beer this
truly tastes exactly like root beer i can't
well can we try i mean you don't like grouper
no i do like root beer but she's weird but germs
wise i'm not sure i'm not offering it to you oh i
was gonna ask about it no i'm not you can't share
sodas in a pandemic i'm pretty sure okay all right
i'm sorry about that god we both had covenants now
we're a podcast but okay but i like it so here's
the thing everyone's home like i don't know i
just feel like you have to make what used to be
very mundane tasks special because we have so few
special things we can do right now you deserve
a little treat treat yourself yeah you know get
yourself a fancy soda that makes you feel special
and like you're um a woman that wasn't allowed
to work in the 50s oh look so much easier back
then that's what i'm aiming for now no pressure
of your career goals lollipop is so confident that
you will love their products that they offer a 100
money back guarantee for orders placed through
their website we've worked out an exclusive deal
for the good for you podcast listeners receive
20 off plus free shipping on their best-selling
variety pack this is a great way to try all of
their delicious flavors go to drink lollipop.com
whitney or use whitney at checkout to claim this
deal that's d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p dot com slash
whitney this discount is valid only for their
variety pack this is just so they put me on the
screen too while you're talking okay well we don't
i know how to not let you take over and steal
my thunder i know that's we're working on if
you guys are watching uh i'm doing things to
just take my moment yeah take her
lollipop can also be found in over 3 000 stores
across the country including whole foods sprouts
kroger wegman and heiron i get why people heckle
it's so tempting yeah it is and it's also hurtful
i'm just sitting here like yeah like i like never
go to a comedy show i don't know how people when
i get mad at people they heckle i know i'm not
mad anymore i'm sorry yeah people didn't let
you talk for an hour yeah it's awful well like one
night when it's so boring when i go to one of your
next shows i'm just going to sit in the
audience and mouth what you're saying
is that me laughing like a joke that's you right
now is there ever a time where you're like i'm
maturing or like i my taste is changing and i
wanna like is my do i have to stay absolutely
i think evolving is such an important part
of you know just in the comedy business for
you probably and also in the internet they don't
let us we just get old and they forget about us
we've never done that before i can't wait
to see what you what what this looks like
no i i feel like yeah there is something called
fan fatigue so if they see the same thing over
and over it's not going to perform as well so you
always have to be evolving yeah but i think in my
case um i was raised you know to be competitive
in sports and then double major and that's all
i knew i didn't really have a social life i i
went to college but i didn't have a social life
and i was up at f 5 a.m to do 6 a.m practice
and then i was in las vegas all day yeah for
volleyball in labs all day i had my game then at
11 30 p.m i'm culturing my stem cells in the lab
like i just had no life at all so i think because
i was on the internet and i know put on my face
i think just the life that i was raised into
i don't know what else to do except to work
hard but this is what i was just having this
conversation with ben and two about about another
thing which is like but there's nothing you've
done that per like prepares you that anyone for
being in charge of people how are you but sports i
think people a lot of times don't understand like
like when they're like i'm going to be a creator
i'm going to be a boss and i'll be this like okay
well do you know how to deal with someone who's
mad at you but not be [ __ ] and not be passive
aggressive and not be like okay well i think
you want me to do this tomorrow and like you
can't do that yeah there's a level of like you can
edit you can write you can be a comedian you can
do this and i can but just engaging different
people's personalities you're the leader it's
like it's like no one prepares you for that do
you know what i mean i mean i guess you must
have gotten it from playing sports because you
have to communicate and you have to like play
having your coaches yell at you and then like
trying to pick up your teammates absolutely and
you have to know how to talk to people for 10
hours a day in this same tight space but this
goes back you just have to be a good person it is
yeah it's survival of the nicest now you have to
now it used to be you had to be talented at first
it was nice guys finished last now i think yeah
you just have to be nice you have to be a genuine
person yeah and if you're not like it's just like
your stuff's not going to be good either because
i think right now people don't want negative toxic
[ __ ] they can't yeah you know but but i just
i think that that's promising i think like the
internet like in a lot of ways people this is like
the worst and it's bringing out all the trolls
and i think it's actually like you know shedding
light and and adding jokes and that's what you're
so amazing at too it's almost like we're providing
almost like free laughs to everybody and hopefully
the ticket prices are going up they're going up
just preparing but still but still i i think that
um in this time in a time of such negativity
i think it is so important to produce laughs
to to our fans and hopefully make this world
a better place i mean yeah i mean and so what
um would you say i'm before we get into this
other thing um uh our surprise uh event for the
show which is me getting tetanus uh from here oh
yeah uh tana's a what would you call it extreme
tattoos what do you use okay so at the start
of quarantine um i went through a rampage of
different quarantine purchases i bought a stripper
pole uh-huh um a lot of other random things
lightsaber chopsticks cute um i mean where's
the lightsaber i mean oh you're onto something
yes and then also a tattoo gun then i just
started tattooing myself and then i tried
tattooing my dad he didn't he wasn't for it and
now a lot of my friends are just yo like i have
i have like 50 friends being like on the
wait list just to get a tattoo from me
okay so you this is like a you just started doing
there's not a there's not like a thing you've
been doing a while i think i've tattooed like 50
people though okay okay okay we're i'm gonna get a
uh a tattoo today from hannah are you actually
i don't know okay let's let's see uh uh yes if
i don't start hemorrhaging i don't know i might
be who knows with my covered blood things might
go sideways do i need to have had a tetanus shot i
feel like i've had one no i had one in 2018. okay
yeah i'm also using a sterilized needle yeah okay
so yeah yeah should be yes yeah no i should clean
off the surface there look honestly after what
just happened with kovid i am if i didn't just
die in the last couple months i'm invincible life
is a simulation wait so this is just a tattoo gun
you've got what do i do oh i'm definitely going
to want i want to do uh emily's name on my foot
and then where do you what's the where what what's
your specialty my specialty is like a smiley face
on the bottom of the foot oh that's like a
no-brainer sure yeah yeah and it's quick too
even i would do that okay yeah it's
gonna tickle though okay let's do it
let's do it let's do it obviously i wanted to do
like a thing back here okay i'm saying i tattooed
somebody's neck yesterday actually wait no out of
this sleeve huh with you hopefully it was shading
she's like i don't want to but disclosure i'm not
a professional and my friends are idiots let's go
not a professional i have health insurance my
friends are idiots i want to die young i got
this on amazon literally for our listeners hannah
is taking her tattoo kit out of a box a clothing
box oh yeah it's just there's a pineapple sticker
on it like do you this is like i do have i think
a sweatshirt came in it's about your you have nine
people working for you and this is the box no it's
fine it's good it's just like you know staff
of nine people and this looks like a yard sale
like this yard what is that blood like what is
on this box champion box like i don't even know
um i want to i want you to talk through setting
this up and i'm going to pee okay cause i just
got scared but i'm just [ __ ] just pooping
i've soiled myself i've soiled myself like as
if there's no backing out now okay so i am okay
plugging this guy in let me move my this paper
so do you want tattoo paper um where i um i draw
it out and then i just it's like a tracing paper
that i pre-brawl it free ball it are you are you
what do you mean racing out whatever emily's a
[ __ ] she you trace hers out you know you
trace mine okay oh wow this is exciting
i have tattoos my tattoos are white mostly
what so i have one right here you can do with
white ink yeah that's a little anchor i've white
because i was like very non-committal this is like
and i told the guy that i'm dating about this
and i was like no i'm not afraid of commitment
my tattoos are just white um i want
them to be there i just don't want
to i just don't want to like have to see
them all the time it's like well that's
a point of tattoo that's why i got this
my my inner lip before i got any tattoo
not the not the response i was expecting yeah
wait so this is it was like an infinity sign
hold on no just because of commitment issues yeah
but what you thought putting it on your lip was
less of a commitment than where that's on my body
so nobody can see it i don't okay okay it's faded
it didn't hurt i i just had a chips and salsa
right afterwards my first tattoo would not be
i know here's the inside of my mouth i know
you're like i'm not i'm i like i'm kind of
not in a tattoo so i put one in my face like
that that's such a cute little hiding place so
invasive i know i would not have thought i'm gonna
hide this in plain sight honestly i know the only
like guys that really see it as my dentist but
isn't that great i was gonna say it's annoying
it's annoying when you have to i find that i have
to lie about my tattoos because i just don't want
to tell the same story over and over again so
people like do you have any tattoos i'm like no
it's like i just don't but you and i don't have
to show them because as soon as someone wants to
see your tattoo you then have to be like okay take
your shirt it's like why do i owe you the all this
information about how many do you have can i see
all of them oh yeah no and then it's just sort of
like why am i and then you have to be like airs on
my lip you have to like touch and then take off my
shoes yeah i do that willingly like my thing is
just like you don't get to see my tattoos like
like you know it's like somebody's like can you
see your tits and it's like sure but there's
something about it like when someone wants your
tattoos you're like fair enough but i'm so excited
because i'm about to tattoo you right now is
this actually happening how long does it like
first of all don't have to shave the area that you
tattoo but are we doing the bottom of your foot
unless you're frodo i think you're good yeah
your feet look fine my feet look fine but there
is like do you ever like get a one random black
hair like on your ankle no you never was like
than i've ever seen at a tattoo store
that's longer than most of them hannah no
no it's not a needle that's a dagger that
is an actual dagger that is a ninja star she's
pulling out a ninja star um a rusty ninja star
i mean this is just do the antibodies protect
from tetanus yeah i read that somewhere
i'm in a covent fog i want you to know that
hannah's taking advantage of my coping fog
yes she's like i'm so excited can we get in there
before whitney's brain clears up and she starts
making good decisions again by the way imagine
when i get back and i dye my hair back and i was
like what happened like i had coven and but and
people are gonna understand okay yeah i had covet
yes like are you doing any more hair colors i
don't know i might i i feel like i'm i'm at i'm
it's getting a little bit like people
are trying to get worried about me
you can only do blue hair for like now it's like
it's like i did ping for a month i did blue for
now it's time to get back to being an adult but
now you're you're you're blue and purple maybe
you just even write it out because the fact
that you know that is a bigger problem what
you didn't know i was like i was like i'm blue
i don't know what color my hair is at this point
which is a bigger issue so yeah i think i need to
get back to being an adult and go back to brown
no yeah you could go full purple no it's here's
the problem is that number one uh i really liked
it at the beginning because when you dye your hair
fully pink people stop asking you for advice and
like help on anything like no one asks for your in
way can you weigh in on this like everyone's good
on anything don't ask her like if people don't ask
you people leave you alone they want you to watch
their kids they don't expect you to like respond
to emails i'm very ticklish do you have ever deal
with people that are so ticklish that it yeah
and then i just scream and i'm like don't move
or else it's gonna look like uh
you know that emoji that's like
and they're all like unsure and their mouths like
squiggly somebody's like yeah that that's happened
before but if you see that you're [ __ ] something
up do you just cover or you just i try to go over
it thicker and just make it a little thicker but
sometimes you will twitch involuntarily should
this camera come in i guess i'm gonna go here
okay is my foot so gross this is so much more
intimate than like getting naked for a man like
you seeing my friends i'm so much more embarrassed
you're about to get so many points on wiki feet
what are you i know this better not ruin my wiki
feed score i feel like i have a five wiki feed
score mostly because aren't that many photos
how tall are you five ten oh nice yeah yeah you're
you're i think we're the same height you just
you haven't you haven't given up yet so you
wear heels i think yeah i wear i wear yeah
yeah no you stick boots with five c's i'm getting
a tattoo yes uh from hannah and what is it to say
is it going to say emily and whitney forever
emily and whitney in a heart do you want that
i mean no but it's funny or we could do the smiley
face oh yeah yeah and then well why don't you do
smiley face on emily i can't do it okay you're
scared i'm scared so e plus w heart but i want
the smiley face let's do the smiley face smiley
face okay and how long does it take to do those i
might i might go over it like twice okay or three
times okay it takes longer to do the sketching
than the actual doing right while we're waiting
for that i would just like to say jen aniston uh
wrote me back uh hannah loves jen aniston and
we sent a video she said she remembers me yes
my name is my name wow guys if you guys don't
know she is literally my um my bad screen my phone
screen holy cow guys what she lit she said she
remembered me yes how do you feel about the fact
that a lot of people feel about you the way you
feel about jazz does that make you want to quite
what you're doing does this make you uncomfortable
about being famous yes because a lot of people i
feel bad for jen you're a lot of people's jedison
so i just want you to know how creepy your life
is she just seems so put together god she's
an actual icon i guess guys she remembers me
we should do i love jan on one and then the
smiley face i will do that i will literally
do that on my forehead all right here we go okay
hold on back why is the anticipation so much worse
than actually doing it okay i've gotten tattoos
before i'm an adult i've just never gotten one on
my phone be careful because am i even able to walk
on my feet is here uh yeah i walked i actually
before covid after i got the hi how are you on
the bottom of my foot i went out and i partied
yeah but you have joy in your heart you are a
happy resilient person i'm hanging by a thread
oh no you'll be good i also have really high
arches so that's perfect it's apparently a
problem it won't wear off yeah it's a problem
for me it's like a problem like great for uh
tattoos on the back i'm supposed to wear insoles
i had bone spurs and me too me too and then i was
like whatever i'd rather just be in pain
and [ __ ] have to go to this appointment
oh yeah that doesn't hurt barely did
anything yeah it doesn't really really need
i turned out my entire body's numb i thought my
who knew it's not just my
oh feels like um it's kind of like what
it feels like when you get an iud put in
it's like a creepy kind of like nettlesome pain
oh she's very focused you do take this very
seriously i'm yeah i'm trying this is like really
what you want to do with your life imagine it's
sweet you're so successful at something and she's
like you're like michael jordan playing baseball
she's like but i just want to be a tattoo artist
it's leaking a little bit but it's okay i'm
just going to do a wipe down this isn't what
it actually looks like ink okay thank you
am i called leaking that's called bleeding
um let me correct let me no okay we're
gonna give you the proper term uh that's
called bleeding that's called a punctured
artery in the foot oh gosh i love that noise
it's such a sexy noise it's such a soothing noise
you're like oh the sound of bad decisions oh
guys when you guys want to suck our feet this
is what we're doing by the way we're like
like you like it and we have to like
that might not have stuck is that a
frowny face did you do the squiggle emoji
no we might i might even wipe it off and
nothing stuck i have a very light hand i
was going to say i it's it doesn't hurt at all
what you're doing but maybe that means really
i need to go indeed i feel it i feel i
need to go in deeper i do feel it i think
i can't tell because i'm trying so hard to trick
myself into not feeling it i don't know if i'm
succeeding or if it's just not deep enough
okay this is gonna be sex all the time i
think i felt that can you just do it again
deeper i just i'm not sure oh yeah nothing
nothing well a little bit a little bit we
are getting there dude it's going to be cute
oh this is so cute all you fetishes just out there
i'm i'm doing this to send you a thumbs up a lot
of women nice smiley faces women who like men to
fetishize their food i'll take the compliment yeah
i'll take it i'm not going to reject a compliment
even if you're mentally ill when you're making it
are you feeling that yeah
that definitely is deeper
okay yeah this is really a sensation that is
unfamiliar to me okay you know what it is it's
just an unfamiliar kind of pain on the foot it's
like it's like tickle pain you know you know what
people are tickling you and you don't want them
to tickle you you know and you're six and they're
not related to you um no that's not so i just
mean like you know when someone's tickling you
oh my gosh that's just like you can never but
you know my god it's tickling you and it like
hurts but you're laughing so they don't
know to stop oh my god oh my goodness
okay i think that's it yeah i think we got
it you've had enough of smelling my foot
she's like i've had enough i just stopped i'm like
i know i did not think to like wash my feet i
thought i was gonna do it back like on my shoulder
what just put it against did i [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] and that's your tattoo did i i mean
look it is very artsy it is very it's like
a moroe painting or like a jackson pollock
it's a visit you did i just [ __ ] it up or no it
doesn't i just got it all over the table i do need
to go over it again we have to do something for
jen we have to do a gen if you're not if you're
not doing the bottom of your foot i'll do the
bottom of my other foot why don't we do i need
to go unless you like it like this i think we
should go over it again okay okay you're the boss
you're the expert i can't see it wait wait can i
um yeah i can't even see it i trust you for some
reason i know before by the way i know it's weird
i really like her and we're like old new friends
you're a stranger to me i mean i don't really
know you you know what i mean yeah i know
wild wild and i'm marking you for life for
life it'll fade doesn't it fade on the bottom
i love it you're like it's fine when you guys
have your epic public falling out it'll fade
don't worry get it covered don't worry ah okay
i think i think and i know i say that every
time but i think that's no good you never know
art is never done only abandoned who said that
leonardo da vinci i think michelangelo sorry
but you didn't know either so okay here we go
what's that water looks good ladies and gentlemen
don't happy foot we don't see gender here happy
feet yeah i mean my feet are so disgusting
maybe this is like helping with a healing
like me embracing my ugly feet that's so cute it's
so cute kiss it i'm kidding put it in your mouth
wait what do you see i don't know do it with it
okay do you like it yes sorry i do want to look
at it i'm realizing do you want me to go over it
i think i should really yeah there's one part that
cute so cute she's like you know what i don't
know here's what i'll say the way someone drives
it drives uh uh uh uh for women we can't drive
um uh the way that a smiley face the way that
the eyes are separated makes him like look so like
happy when i draw a smiley face they look evil and
lost and dangerous they're
just i know it's like eyebrows
yeah when i draw a smiley face they look like
their eyebrows are furrowed like even the way you
shoot or even just the eyes like like your circles
are your little like like it's just like a happy
happy face my happy face my happy faces look like
they're faking it my happy faces look like it's
just two more times okay there's just two more
sections having so the one on top of your foot
did that hurt like all [ __ ] oh yeah oh and plus
that was a cover-up of another tattoo but i think
because it was a cover-up it they like damaged
the nerves on the first time so it didn't really
hurt that much this is just army hammer's face i
had to remove that tattoo ah oh a good goo bob oh
so basically the more you're going over it
the more it's already wounded skin as you go
on you got it so you're basically jamming
a needle into an open wound got it i got it
i got it oh yeah there we go is it good yeah
cute good look at that i mean we've adorned the
ugliest part of my body i'm so does this mean
i'm a partner in the brand yeah merch like so
this is so i just get like 20 percent 20 yeah
company i'm not like i'm not doing this for fun
yes just sleeping in court how would i not have
been a partner how would i not have been a partner
in her merch company why would i have gotten a
tattoo of it oh extreme tattoo merch would be
cool she told me verbally fifty percent of the
company yeah um okay let's do it on this side
let's do i love jen jennifer aniston yeah i want
that on me well [ __ ] you haven't done it and i'm
we're on my podcast now i think you'll
get what we'll get this matching tattoo
this might take a while though like it might this
like to do all that it might take like 30 minutes
how about just i heart j i heart j okay i'm
fully getting an i love jennifer aniston tattoo
and that's the best tattoo ever i'm probably
gonna go home and tattoo it on myself
can you do your own foot yeah you're right i did
my own foot i tattooed that's crazy on my toes
it's all black and blue right now but it's okay
that ugh what a nightmare i just feel like yeah
the toes would probably be super like it's like
you know when i derma roll on the face which is
the thing with the tiny needles to put the
make sure that all your product is absorbing
your face over the lip is the worst like it's
just so random where we have nerve endings
oh does this one hurt more
because it's more like dead skin
tattoo artists are so bomb because
and hot because you're you're most nervous and you
want to talk and make small talk and they won't
do anything oh no you can't it's due it's hot
dude i was i was tattooing uh this girl's neck
last night and i wasn't breathing and after i
would stop a stroke i would be like oh because
you like didn't want to breathe down her neck
or something i know i just i feel like i'm more
you're dead i'm more like i have a steadier hand
it's almost like uh if you're playing call of duty
and you're like doing like a sniper shot and then
the the character is like after you you hit it
because they like hold the breath do you
guys we haven't even talked to you guys play
you want to play tonight i'll see you in the goo
leg what does any of this mean dave do you play
what is what is she saying is she harassing you uh
no what does that mean what's the gu lag it's uh
where you go when you die and i just call it
call of duty i'm not good at a war zone at
all so i'm just like but i do win a lot in gulag
are you just doing this to just show people how
shitty a girlfriend i am compared to you is this
what this whole podcast i am doing this because
i'm alone and i need friends so these are like
virtual friends i can just talk to it's like so
you've never met any of the people you game with
in person oh no i i game i game with a lot of my
guy friends yeah okay yeah what's your and this is
on twitch uh it it could be on twitch if you want
to stream it okay however you could just play and
not even stream it just for fun until 5am every
night you're very patient about uh explaining
this to me without having judgment in your voice
exhaustion what happened to that what what what
do you ever want to game live like in stadiums
oh when i had energy i i just have dollar signs
in my eyes i'm like would you like to tour yeah
like i'm literally just well i just
created this game room in my house and
normal well normal gamers game rooms are like
just very futuristic you shouldn't you should
you should design arcades i should because
my game or my game room is literally like
the hannah stocking experience the promised
rainforest cafes they're really really fun but
the water [ __ ] stinks oh like the what they
ever noticed that you got a rainforest cafe
yeah i did actually and it's like tap when the
water comes on you're like oh yeah is that sewage
water like what's the like yes like everyone's
kind of you can tell the waiters are bummed when
the water goes off there's like the mess yeah
the waiters are just like slipping on the floor
they're like enjoy your [ __ ] potatoes like it
is like and then every now and then when when the
lightning would go off and the gorillas are like
oh god the waitress is there like oh [ __ ] god
hit in the face with a toucan again oh what a
fun welcome to rainforest cafe it's not making
me laugh just like is it a teardrop or is it like
a sewage droplet from the rain this is so dumb
and i'm so into it dude for me this is when else
are we gonna be able to do dumb like [ __ ] that's
like right i think the pandemic let's take
something good away from it which is like that
thing you've been putting off or that thing you're
like i can't do that just [ __ ] that's where
my hair is purple and i'm getting foot tattoos
that's why i started tattooing it's like who cares
your fullest thing it's it's the uh live like
you're gonna die tomorrow because you [ __ ] might
like what have you been not doing because you're
like i'll do that later in my life i'll do that
in my head just just do it now for the [ __ ]
of you like do it this weekend mm-hmm because
you don't know how long yeah it's amazing you can
always stop you can't you know you can always dye
your hair back brown people say like oh your
hair's blue now i'm like yeah no yeah you know
yeah no no it doesn't stay permanent you know
how hair works it's gonna grow out but tattoos
[ __ ] that's really good you guys have
a tattoo without permanent as a tattoo
guys i don't know the basic concept of a
tattoo does that hurt nope it's a tiny pain okay
cool it's a little baby pain it's like a little
toddler just like stabbing you with their baby's
knife you can't be mad it's like a cute pain yeah
hold on move your foot like that oh wow okay
just a lot of confidence i am not tired hold on
yeah why don't you here we go okay yeah you're i'm
fully making you like engage your core to do this
jen's going to see this
by the way she still wants to get this right
it's so sweet when in doubt do it for jen
who are your favorite tattoo artists um there's
this guy named um uh jack townsend who's really
good and also this other guy uh n dot a dot l
he's really really far uh-huh yeah if you're
you have to be good to have that annoying of a
name you must be good for people to say dot dot
like that you have to be an instagram name i'm
not really sure what you know he's the best
tattoo artist he must be because yeah you can't
have that name and not be and be like mediocre
yeah um all right the j did not stick at all
so here we go we will go again j round two
you could also do courtney or lisa look at
that let's see let's see so how how did you
and jennifer aniston meet i'm just she reached
out and was like i'm dying to be friends with you
you can't are you serious no i i i found i gotta
i went and i bought a star maps uh drove to her
house and um they sound like me something
i would do yeah and they just you know it's
usually through one of her security guards that i
get a message the way they relay it like she's so
good she's just so busy she's very busy she's busy
and usually just the lapd will deliver a message
from her to me to my home it's titled restraining
order yeah yeah yeah yeah she's like me
she's like meet me downtown next week and i'm like
cool at this courthouse cool she loves to hang out
at the courthouse you feel this yeah hell yeah i'm
trying to like talk and like nervously distract
myself but that one's not bad that's not bad
that's like a good pain okay that hurts so good do
not call me army always so she's always so shocked
i am there's going to be a point she's so shocked
when i like uh say crazy [ __ ] there will come
a time in your life too where you stop giving a
yeah like and it's not now it is you're not
a very absolute i feel like again whenever
you're saying uh you still have a lot
to build don't throw it all away yet
by saying the dumb [ __ ] i say that's not
worth it i know don't burn bridges the way
i and when you say that stuff i'm just like i
just like to i'm i'm literally got a backpack
full of grenades and i'm just like i have been so
beaten down by this business that i'm just like
i'm just throwing grenades left and right
i love it as you should though i just don't
even give a [ __ ] anymore um uh oh are you no
is this not the big reveal no and i don't even
have a backup career i don't know what the [ __
] i'm thinking you have like nine backup careers
this will need a few more times to go over okay
we have a really good base layer though yeah but
that's like thicker skin on top it is very thick
thick with five shoes but i think this is like
it's you know it's like shadowy
it has a really really cute shadow
undertone and it kind of reminds me of your white
tattoos the ones that no one can see well do you
want to reveal what you tattooed on me will you
just break my foot so i can i can't i want to
i can't because i still need to take a
lot of the income what does it look like
what does it say is it like a
dick uh not a dick a spaceship
a spaceship with two engines yeah two engines on
either side okay so oh no no bad it's good it will
be good here's why am i going to get sued you get
worse before you get better and that's this this
is going to be worse before you better the only
thing i don't want to hear from my tattoo artist
i want to hear from like anyone else
anyone but okay wait i'll take a picture
also not all the ink is off i mean
it looks it looks like like um it looks like i
just lightly put pencil over it looks like um
um it looks like
it looks like do you remember in true detective
when the serial killer carved into the tree
it's kind of like that uh only on my body forever
uh no i i genuinely think this will go away in
like two days no i love it i'm dude it's the
bottom of my foot yeah i think it has a lot
of personality it's good and then i've got this
little guy oh yeah this one's this one's a keeper
so dumb they're so funny yeah i normally like
never let anyone see my feet but now i'm going
to start to just be proud and i yeah i had really
bad athletes foot in high school when i played
basketball and it was like so embarrassing that i
think i have like trauma around my feet being out
but not anymore lucky your lucky day hello oh
it looks amazing it's so cute i love it all
right and while you're disassembling i want to
ask you a question yeah about like your future
like looking for like do you want to be in movies
and television or you're just like that's a waste
of time i'm building a business i love that i i
love that that realm you want to be less famous
i want to go to hollywood just to have less
people see what i do here's the thing i do
think that there is a stigma uh between um
traditional media there's internet media
and i know this but it's not that real it's
we're jealous and we're jealous and we're mad
but uh i kind of like i just want to mesh the
two i know like a few of my internet friends
are doing a great job doing that but i would
love to be in traditional media don't really
care what it pays yeah but i just want to be
you know that internet person that helps blend
that's fascinating yeah you should do a you
already could have done a movie i mean like but
jackass like that was really like they were kind
of just like they just scrambled it all together
yeah you know what i'm saying you probably already
have enough footage to put a movie together
yeah just compile it all yeah like a document
like a big like compilation video i am and i am
going to be in a movie though it's coming out
yeah one movie uh it's called um vanquisher
cool by directed by george gallo why are you so
you're like i could you have a little bit of like
freeman's in it you have like shyness around it i
know i just i can't i can't believe it that's just
you go in an audition or do they just give it to
you they uh um they are really good friends with
my mom but let me ask you do you by the way um
would you uh do you ever feel like when you get
hired for something they call you in and you're
like oh they want me to post like something john's
saying i wouldn't say for that movie specifically
but yes i have been hired on like other things
where yeah they're like so like the social
media not not this project that i'm talking
about but like previous ones that i won't name
yeah yeah i have been like okay well here's our
socials this is our at our hashtag i'm just like
yeah yeah because i know like you're here today
obviously so that i'll post about you i know
you're using me for my following it's fine i'm
fine with it you're a hustler collective it's
friendship you get more out of this than i do
and that's fine i'm fine i'm a giver i want to
support the next generation of women in comedy
whatever i can do to help you boost your numbers
hey yes and my future uh comedy stand-up show
because there's also this weird thing that i think
is important to say that out loud like because
it doesn't occur this i i'm gonna go on a rant
everyone just settle in uh get cozy uh grab a
drink all right um uh i was on a set yesterday
because of the covet i don't know if i know
i mentioned this but i was on a set yesterday
did everyone get that and they brought up three
times four times um no but it was it was with
covid like normally there's like people going
like with the wardrobe and then and there's all
these like union rules where you let people do
their thing in the clothes and you know and they
get your mic but with kovid it was very much like
you do everything yourself and just you know it
was like but the rules are also very amorphous
and vegan you didn't really know or whatever but i
found myself the first time in a really long time
remembering advice that i got from my dad that um
blew my mind which in relationships i was always
the one that loved too much i was always the one
that did everything i was always the one that gave
too much i was always and um he said something to
me once he was like be careful how self-sufficient
you come off because it never occurs to anyone to
help you never encourage anyone that you need help
right so if you're not going to ask for help
because i had a hard time asking for help or
being able to acknowledge any kind of weakness
and then uh trying to become so self-sufficient
so everyone thinks i'm a strong woman and not
needy and weak or fragile and i was on set and
i was like i'm so thirsty and i'm sorry but how
would anyone know that and i'm in a mask and
people can't read my face and whatever yeah but
in terms of like like you and like hollywood there
are a lot of assumptions like your name comes
up and stuff and people like ah she's [ __ ] so
rich why would she ever want to do this or like
or whatever or she's so she's got her own thing
going why did you want do you mean like there is
someone that needs to connect the world's going
we want to be in business with you you want
to be in business with us let's figure out the
way that works where we're both blending the two
words right now they're like circling each other
with a a resentment of like uh but
but but then there's some amazing like
huge movie stars like kevin hart and the rock
and they have massive social media followers yeah
they take it very seriously yeah yeah so there's
that aspect and then there's like oh yeah oh you
you just do i can't post anything about that
that would look bad yeah but yeah yeah that's
really what happens is you you're already in a
situation where you have a bunch of people like
making sure your business right you're then
you're just if you get in business with big
corporations they're just gonna go like
and you can't have coke in this photo yeah
it just becomes it becomes about that [ __ ]
but that's just business that's just business
i know but yeah i i mean i think it's it's a lot
better than what it was about like four or five
years ago it was absolutely you cannot be in this
movie because of that and then it started becoming
like oh i would love for this girl to be in this
movie because yeah she could pose about it or
or benefit it and then i won't spend as much
money on advertising for this movie because i
have her that's stupid it is but at least it's
kind of starting to mesh they should pay you
for posting uh yeah that is that is a not this
podcast but other productions should pay you
no but it's like no that's a different service so
it's like it's like this is why hollywood needs to
[ __ ] catch up fast because they're going okay um
no one's watching anything so let's just put you
in this cause you'll post about it later it's like
no [ __ ] write the part for her make it jersey
just let's write the movie for her yeah and then
it's organic and natural it's it's that doesn't
work they tried to do it i saw it happen where
influencers would come on and do tv shows for
sweeps week it did not bump the numbers it doesn't
matter because your fans they get your internet
yeah yes it's like that would be new fans they
would follow you but not the metrics are showing
they don't follow right away they're watching you
on set like i'm on the set of this marvel movie
and da da da da i mean maybe that's different
tomorrow maybe it'll like come out or whatever
and your fans if they're younger they have to
get their mom to help but it's like yes for
the most part they're like oh my god hannah's on
whatever this weekend i'll watch it this weekend
like i'll get to it eventually because they've
got you right here in their hand mm-hmm yeah so
it's just it's just like it's such a different
that just really pisses me off because it's like
i feel like so many content creators hollywood
didn't either or get or they didn't do the
system or they didn't go through it and they're
like i'm just gonna [ __ ] do this on my own
yeah or they didn't give them a chance because
i still feel like movie acting is different than
internet acting yeah obviously so then if people
see you know like somebody acting crazy or doing
like a weird persona because it connects with
the kids yeah they're seeing that as oh this girl
can't do a dramatic role but it's like you know
they do that they do that no matter what if you
want a sitcom they'd say it if you were in a drama
they'd say you can't do comedy everyone needs to
say something about you that's not true so they
feel better today because they're you know what i
mean it's like it never ends yeah but everybody
needs to know internet acting is different
than it's also real acting and yeah sitcom versus
serious roles but it's also like a lot of people
that are watching like it's like it's almost
like um there's some videos that are like almost
reminiscent to me because a lot of people are
watching with the sound off and they're on going
from here to here it's like a two minute bite a
five minute bite whatever um and uh it's almost
like some of them feel like like like charlie
chaplin or something the physical humans tell us
to be able to communicate with just is so
refreshing especially because i feel like
comedy is going in this direction with a lot of
[ __ ] that's how that's how i feel like that's
how it gets yeah sorry i feel like that's how um
like especially like internet videos get global
leave viral they transcend because it's language
barrier and uh yeah exactly like language but it's
also like i think that's so important to say that
because like whenever like snobby comedians are
like oh this is like and you're like but that they
that's what you're supposed to that's for that
do you know what i'm saying yeah that's it's
like it has to be super visual medium you have
to communicate a ton with your face really
really quickly in body language and then
go into like certain characters if
you're talking about your mom like do
your little thing or whatever yeah i think
siblings yeah i have a i have older sister
yeah let's get along very different she's
a doctor and she lives in washington
what kind of doctor uh she uh she helps
people give birth wow that's why i know
that's wild yep has everything together she
cleans i don't um yeah she has chickens i'm
like staring at you i'm kind of obsessed with you
you just like there's not a lot of darkness that
happens with you like you know what we went over
this i suppress i suppress and suppress as soon
as we called countries but only my lawyers no but
you but do you like i i very much i've struggled
my whole life with uh silence and and like like
when there's a silent moment especially in front
of cameron's enough you can usually see someone
unravel and you're just like oh really oh that's
such a nice compliment thank you it's like it's
really whatever like between the therapy and your
parents i don't know who owes the compliment but
i'm just so impressed so you see people unravel in
moments of silence no it's just like you know
that when like when there's a silent moment
you're just claiming your space and you're
going it's your job to ask me another question
do you know what i'm saying that
is so funny where's comedians
i need to learn that skill maybe it's the the
virus load see if you're just trying to not get
my job it's like i'm just like no but there's
something interesting about like like that that
has just taken me so long of like any time you're
like even on a date or on a freaking job interview
whatever it is like when you just it's quiet so
you just start kind of running your mouth oh yeah
i used i used to do that um but i got over it
when you're done talking you just stop talking
but i'm saying that's a skill like i
don't like that's just a good skill
also it's a skill in your sense that you can just
think of topics off the top of your head and just
and keep going with it yeah and run with it yeah
yeah no i i'd rather do yours yours looks more fun
yours looks more like a fun life choice um
okay last thing i'm going to ask you because
we do this on the podcast with everyone is um
red flags in the podcast i always want someone
to walk away with like a new like i don't know
insider piece of advice or just something or
um i'm gonna ask you the best advice you've
gotten and then any red flags in relationships
the best advice that i've gotten i would say
recently i saw something online it wasn't like
somebody told it to me it was don't worry about
if they like you worry about if you like them
right write that down everybody
oh but i don't like anyone
oh no no no if that's the case and i never see
anybody but it kind of it kind of goes back to
what we're talking about like oh i hope i didn't
hurt their feelings or whatever like you know
just worry about yourself your feelings and take
care of yourself it's taken me i mean that is like
i mean that's like that's like a gnarly concept
that i like wish i had heard earlier in my life
because i was like i just heard that last week
too and i just been replaying in my head on repeat
like you know when you hear like a great piece of
advice and you're like where were you 15 years ago
exactly my whole life and like if someone
wants to be friends with me like well you
get to be friends with me yeah if someone wants
to date me it's like what am i going to say no
i guess we're just together now okay i'm going
to wait until you cheat on me or something like i
just have to become such an [ __ ] that you break
up with me like uh like i had such a reactive
take on uh people's approval that's so interesting
and then yeah we run around and then it's also i'm
like uh if something's negative online
you go to your profile and you're like
i'm looking at your profile you're [ __ ]
loser you've contributed nothing to society
i still i'm still upset that you don't like
me i know you don't even know you proceed
i know um regarding red flags so i think
i i just have too many uh probably like
little ones that's good that's there's no such
thing as too many uh too much self-respect i
have too many red flags there's so many i mean i
could i could go up i could go on and on and on
but obviously a clear red flag is if you're
hanging out you know with a guy for the
first time and can't get off his phone he's
hiding the phone no no no that's yeah that's
no no car if you know like he just asks you
to move in off the top he doesn't have credit
cards that's just you that's not other other
women are like it's never happened before um
yeah i don't know um
steals from you this is getting very
autobiographical and um do you need to borrow
some money are you okay do you need some should
we hey so i know um yes it's real specific um
um
oh that was lemaire but whatever um
those are good those are good those are like
that was great your your red flag but yeah
they're i like the smaller non-obvious
ones the little ones the little ones
little like that those are the like little
ones like um oh if he i i think if he acts
like completely different around his
friends than he does with you personally
i've never met any of my boyfriend's friends
hmm that might be a red flag too wait you've met
wait but guys you date larry you meet what his
friends oh huh by the way i just got stuck on this
thing with my necklace um yeah what do you mean oh
to [ __ ] them in front of him oh yeah okay oh um
i don't know why that like raised something
in my head no i um i also think if they
speed in parking garages red flag that is
maybe the best one i've heard really 100
yeah like they don't care about themselves
they don't care about their car their
personal belongings they don't care about people
walking to their car that is such a good one also
unnecessarily backing into the space so you can
save time pulling out yeah you're not like you're
like the the amount of time you're like guys have
to pull in back into the hardest possible space or
something yeah i don't know what they're like yeah
why are there so many tire streaks what screech
is going on in the freaking parking garages why
didn't but why don't you just pull in and back out
like a lot of red flags happen in parking garages
a lot yeah how long it takes you to get out of
your car if you know somebody's waiting to take
your parking if you ever date a man and hear
the tire screech in a parking garage if he's not
logan paul if he doesn't you know what i'm saying
he's not doing it for as a career he's not a
race car driver if he's not a lewis hamilton
yeah i don't know what that is um but um that's
such a good one yeah oh [ __ ] that's a good one
um what else drive recently uh i had a weird
little one guys that delete texts as they go
oh and dms i don't know i don't even know
you can do that i always delete my dm's in
texts just to happen how did you develop
that habit and why what are you hiding
yeah red flag that's a great one
too wow but what is it with you
with with why do you guys have to dm
on instagram why can't you just text
like what is this snapchat i'm
saying why is everybody's snapchat
i thought that was gone i thought snapchat
disappeared not just the messages i thought the
entire app disappeared so that's on you and you
need to get new friends but uh no but i don't um
you know that all that's like going to like
facebook owns everything we text on instagram
yeah exactly yeah bad yeah imessage whatsapp
facetime not call me why is it dms yeah
interesting following porn stars or lingerie
models yeah i'm good liking all their pictures
just google porn and watch it when you want to
alone yeah why are you making me know why are
you making the public also why do you know like
look at a naked girl during the day like just
as you're looking at you don't know what that's
going to be sandwiched in between on your feet
yeah yeah i mean your niece is like porn star
boyfriend oh you know i don't know how your grids
i don't know exactly i don't know what else you
follow i know i know and then it pops up on your
for you page or not for you page the explore page
and then you're like oh why why is this here oh
i see the guy i'm talking to like okay wait wait
are you telling me that your explore page gives
you insight on the guy you're dating yeah who
they follow because yeah you've been dea sometimes
sometimes it pops up once in a blue moon yeah
you can find out that's the tea i know that's the
full right there not only is that the tea i
need to like i need to like make some calls
like it's like it may be like i need to put
on my instagram right now that's the type of
information that is like changes your life in a
way that might not be good oh yeah i know i know
that that's a dice like i haven't even put that
together because i like my explore page is all
like girls twerking and i'm always like i guess
it's because i follow cardi b and i don't know
yeah he's probably important but he follows
a look at his follows this could be because
it's like the top five people that you text
with the most because also if you if i if you
text me my birthday's coming up which it came and
it's raining out i'll get ads for an umbrella oh
on the thing yeah so i had this whole conversation
with someone uh uh at the internet um i talked to
the internet guy you say that i talked to the
president of the internet and um he told me uh
that it's the top five people that you dm with and
then if they say it's my birthday or it's whatever
and then they'll market you things that that
person has clicked on or googled on their computer
on their wi-fi which is a separate cord which just
makes it especially impressive very impressive
robots technology are we in a simulation or not
this is out of out of control but very smart i
love you i end this very awkwardly um what do you
want to talk about because let's be honest you
need promotion for your thing you're struggling in
your career oh my goodness i love you more whitney
thank you so much for having me on the podcast
i always have so much fun hanging out i'm always
curious um i think i've just i do not recommend it
it's just like it's just like hard it's hard it's
it's it's hard for my personality type because
i'm just like beat myself up too much but what um
i'm just curious if that's something that that
i think it's something that might maybe happen
will happen down the road because you are uh yeah
i'm just curious because for someone like you it's
really a matter of not what you're gonna do it's
when you're gonna do it and like in what order
yeah i think that's definitely down the road and
then there's this pressure to do like everything
right the second i know you're a woman and
you're managing everything else that i've just
got on board with and then you can do a
podcast any time that's what i'm saying
do that when you're like like done like yeah
when you're ready to look like this every day
and when you're ready to just let let people think
that you've had a manic break and you don't care
because i'm still getting over
here um who cares if i like you
not if they like you oh see
of course i turned it into
um uh so okay so there's this the last thing
i'll say is there's a george haas does this um
attachment style class that helps you change your
attachment strategy you i see the link no i think
you're secure no no i think your intimacy
issues abandonment yeah that's the opposite
abandonment issues are a form of intimacy
issues don't let me blow your mind but i will
your brain just yeah your face
just first my eyes starts bleeding
just make the camera side eye i just i know it's
like the tear but can you just cheat the camera
like she's something horrible happens someone
like can you cheat the camera i'm just like
just cheat out just banana out banana banana just
rag zoom focus real quick um i forgot what was it
something i love you keep going okay so i love
you okay so george haas the whole thing is like
codependence we get entrenched in relationships
and we don't uh uh even if it's toxic and
and it's addictive it's hard to leave right um
and uh the uh like the familiar pain is better
than the unfamiliar unknowing pain but the
whole thing blah and uh there's a meditation
uh for preoccupied attachment styles which
is like anxious when you're like worried the
person's abandoning you or leave or you know you
only text me once today or she didn't call me back
at this time you know that what are they doing
that old stuff yeah that comes up um and uh uh
the inner child reactions and the the meditation
is i love you keep going like i love you like
keep going so so what do you do you meditate and
then you say that in your head you kind of just
say in your head i love you keep going and it's
there's a little bracelet like it's just a a a
it sounds kind of like like whatever but it's it's
actually really powerful and rewiring your brain
that's not like i love you you need to be at my
disposal all the time because relationships can't
grow if you're suffocating each other so it's like
you go out with your friends go have experiences
i'm gonna separation is healthy yeah come back
in and now i have something to talk to you about
because we're not together twenty four [ __ ]
times and it keeps it alive and i love you keep
going keep growing like because if i don't want
you in five years to go like i'm the same person
i was five years ago because of this like you have
to keep growing and relationships yeah and um but
i am like so codependent [ __ ] up we were all
going to go get tattoos and we didn't by the way
um and uh we were like going down to
the tattoo thing and i had heard the
meditation that day and um we went down i was
like oh so what is it i love you don't leave me
and they were like no i'm like no keep going
that's not that's so good by the way the white
eagles it's amazing but i love that the idea that
i thought that was the saying i know you're like i
need a check-in it's the opposite i have you don't
need me like i'm just like but yeah but it's um
uh i'm very excited i have a new tattoo
two new tattoos who knew and we will
we'll we'll go over that no we'll have another
session yeah we'll go down to the doctor's face
we'll go to her house actually mark mahoney yeah
hey jen can you pay to have this removed this is
technically your fault i'm i'm gonna be there
too just to make sure i think she's gonna pay
for the dr tatoff session yes to fix the the
tetanus in my body oh my goodness uh i love
you so much what a dream um don't write elephants
uh that's what i say at the end of every podcast
uh don't ride elephants um mostly uh african
elephants can't be tamed hannah i love you thank
you for doing this even though it probably hurt
your career quite frankly um oh my gosh i love you
so much like you haven't done a ton of podcasts
no this is my third one that's so wild simon rex
impulsive and now this yeah that's right i haven't
listened to you on logan paul's show really yeah
i also tattooed somebody on there what yeah i
thought you saw that i thought you know i did
it no i don't watch impulsive sorry that's not my
go-to program at night logan oh my gosh i actually
love you i think i'm going on it oh yeah i was
supposed to really yeah i was supposed to go on
with him mike all such great great guys yeah i
don't know them but i i don't do well with like
hot um successful men i get mad at them i'm sorry
oh yeah and logan's like i just dropped three
mail on some pokemon cards i'm like i get that i'm
like but how like i get very like adversarial with
men like rich hot young men i'm just like but
what if you [ __ ] donated i get like i think
yo my my abs are sore from rapping so much you
are so funny i appreciate you so much for having
me here i love you we're gonna make you come back
and i'm sorry i better come back i love you guys
you